on the topic of friendship you do an
amazing podcast called all in podcast
people should stop listening to this and
go listen to that you just did your
100th episode
um I mean it's one of my favorite
podcasts it's incredible for the
the the technical and the human
psychological wisdom that you guys
constantly give and any way you analyze
the world but also just the chemistry uh
between the between you you're clearly
there's there's a tension and there's a
camaraderie that's all all laid out on
on the table so
I don't know the two Davids that well
but I have met Jason what do you love
about him I mean I'll I'll give you a
little psychological breakdown of all
three of these guys sure
um just my opinion yeah and I love you
guys
um would they agree with your
psychological breakdown I don't know you
know I I think that what I would say
about Jay Cal is
he is
unbelievably loyal
um to no end
and you know he's like any of those
movies
where which are about like the the mafia
or whatever where like you know
something bad's going wrong and you need
somebody to show up
that's gcal so if you killed the said
proverbial homeless person he would be
right there yeah but he's the one that
he'll defend you in every way shape or
form even if it's not doesn't make sense
in that moment he doesn't see
that as an action of whether it'll solve
the problem he sees that as an act of
Devotion to you your friend and that's
an Incredible Gift that he gives us
the other side of it is that you know
jaycal needs to learn
how to trust that other people love him
back as much as he loves us
and that's where he makes mistakes
because he assumes that he's not as
lovable as the rest of us
but he's infinitely more lovable than he
understands he's I mean you have to see
Lex like he is
unbelievably funny I mean I cannot tell
you how funny this guy is
um Next Level funny is timing timing
everything charm the care he takes
so he is as lovable but he doesn't
believe himself to be and that manifests
himself in areas that drive us all crazy
from time to time which makes it for a
very pleasant listening experience okay
so what about the the two Davids David
sacks and Dave Friedberg David sacks is
the one that I would say I have the most
emotional connection with
um
he and I can go a year without talking
and then we'll talk for four hours
straight and then we know where we are
and we have this ability to pick up and
have a level of intimacy with each other
and I think that's just because I've
known David for so long now
um
that I find really comforting and then
Freeburg is this person who I think
similar to me had a very turbulent
upbringing has fought through it to
build an incredible life for himself and
I have this enormous respect for his
journey I don't particularly care about
his outcomes to be honest but I just
have I look at that guy and I think
and he did it and so if I didn't do it
um I'll be glad that he did it if it
makes any sense
um
and you can see that he
um feels like his entire responsibility
is really around his kids
and just kind of like
give a better counterfactual
and uh
and you know sometimes I think he gets
that right and wrong but he's a very
special human being that way I'm not
sure the two of you have a very kind of
like from a geopolitics perspective I
don't know there's just a very
uh effective way to think deeply about
the world the big picture of the world
he's a very systems level thinker
yeah very very absolutely
very systems levels very rooted in you
know a broad body of knowledge which I
have a tremendous respect for he brings
all these things in
sax is incredible because he has this
unbelievable understanding of things but
it has a core nucleus so free bird can
just basically abstract a whole bunch of
systems and talk about it
um I tend to be more like that where I
try to kind of I find it to be more of a
puzzle socks is more like anchored in
you know a philosophical and historical
context as the answer
and he starts there but he gets to these
profound understandings of systems as
well on the podcast in life you guys
hold to your opinion pretty strong
uh what's uh what's the secret to being
able to argue passionately with friends
so hold your position but also not
murder each other which you guys seem to
come close to I think it's like strong
opinions weekly held
can you explain that please yeah like
you know like look today you and I yeah
what have we we Steel Man like the two
sides of three different things yeah
um now you could be confused and think I
believe in those things I believe that
it's important to be able to
intellectually Traverse there whether I
believe in it or not and like steel man
not screaming like that's a really but
we introde those things by saying let us
steal men in this position sometimes you
guys skip the uh we skip you're right we
we edit those things out and sometimes
we'll sit on either sides and we'll just
kind of bat things back and forth just
to see what the other person thinks so
that's how like as fans we should listen
to that sometimes like so sometimes
because you hold the strong opinion
sometimes uh like for example the cost
of energy going to zero
is that
like what's the degree of certainty on
that is is this kind of like you really
taking a prediction of how the world
will unroll and if it does this will
benefit uh a huge amount of companies
and people that will believe that idea
so you really you you like uh you spend
a few days a few weeks with that idea
I've been spending two years with that
idea and that idea has manifested into
um many pages and pages of more and more
branches of a tree
but it started with that idea so if you
think about this tree this logical tree
that I built I would consider it more of
a mosaic and at the at the base or root
however you want to talk about it is
this idea the incremental cost of energy
goes to zero how does it manifest and so
I talked about one traversal which is
the competition of households versus
utilities
but if even some of that comes to pass
we're going to see a bunch of other
implications from a regulatory and
Technology perspective if some of those
come to pass so I've tried to think
think
sort of this you know six seven eight
hops forward
and I have some like to use the chest
analogy I have a bunch of short lines
which I think can work
um and I've started to test those by
making Investments
tens of millions over here to 100
Millions over there
but it's a distribution based on how
probabilistic I think this these
outcomes are
and how downside protected I can be and
how much I will learn how many mistakes
I can make you know Etc
and then very quickly over the next two
years some of those things will happen
or not happen and I will rapidly
re-underwrite
and I'll rewrite that tree
and then I'll get some more data I'll
make some more Investments
and I'll rapidly re-underwrite so you
know in order for me to get to this tree
maybe you can ask how did I get there it
was complete accident
the way that it happened was I have a
friend of mine who works at a great
organization called Fortress his name is
Drew McKnight and he called me one day
and he said hey I'm doing the deal will
you anchor it we're going public
and it's a rare earth mining company and
I said Drew like if
I'm going to get tired and feathered in
Silicon Valley for backing a mining
company and he said just talk to the guy
and learn
and the guy Jim lotinski blew me away
he's like here's what it means for
energy and here's what it means for the
supply chain here's what it means for
the United States versus China
but LAX I did that deal and then I did
seven others and that deal made money
the seven others
but I learned I made enough mistakes
where the net of it was I got to a
thesis that I believed in I could see it
and I was like okay
I paid the price I acquired the learning
I made my mistakes I know where I am at
and this is step one
and then I learned a little bit more I
made some more Investments and that's
how I that's how I do the job that's the
minute that you try to wait for
perfection in order to make a bet either
on yourself or a company
a girlfriend whatever it's too late